à l'âge de 11 ans megan grenier richard
prêt quand le centre de pédiatrie
sociale du dr juliette d'anchois gars
c'est l'enfant qui l'entouré dessus sur
des perches
les intervenantes du centre sont pour
elle presque des membres de sa famille
des fois il niche et moi on avait un
plan comme on avait sur icade en mer
jaune a fait un plan j'ai trouvé noyé
après la fellation on avait des
privilèges
ça s'est bien passé un soutien apprécié
par sa mère les enfants cotisait avec ce
besoin le grillon tout mignon des
services sur des activités
ils sont écoutés et ils sont respectés
qui sont allées sont à l'écouté de leurs
besoins il ya un enfant sur trois dans
ces quartiers défavorisés là qu'arrive à
l'école avec déjà en retard dans leur
développement
donc c'est vraiment pour donner tous les
outils à ses enfants le pour atteindre
leur plein potentiel
la guignolée du dr julien
une tradition bien ancrée depuis 17 ans
les 40 centres de pédiatrie sociale de
la province participent à l'événement à
montréal
l'objectif est de 1 million 700 mille
dollars cette guignolée pour la
pédiatrie sociale prend un sens
particulier cette année avec la
commission spéciale sur les droits des
enfants et la protection de la jeunesse
la mort de la fillette degré mme b a
remis tout le système en question la
pédiatrie sociale tentent justement
d'éviter que des enfants tombent entre
les mailles du filet le docteur julien a
déposé un mémoire à la commission
et toutes ces recommandations le tourne
autour de l'idée du saint protecteur des
enfants
la parole de l'enfant du réflexe enfin
dans tous les systèmes québécois mais on
est loin de ce record mais on a bon
espoir qu'avec la commission plus
vraiment mort c'est un processus à long
terme qui met l'enfant au centre de nos
préoccupations
en attendant il faut financer ces
centres les dons sont acceptés jusqu'au
15 janvier en ligne et par textos
donnez pas seulement aujourd'hui donner
tout le temps ouvrez vos yeux créer des
communautés
allez voir votre voisin intéressez vous
à ce qui se passe autour de vous voilà
ici marie josée pas quelques mots radio
canada montréal